en el vídeo pasado teníamos un campo
magnético que iba de derecha a izquierda
y además teníamos un circuito por el
cual estaba pasando una corriente en
esta dirección
utilizando la regla de la mano derecha
vimos que la fuerza que ejercía este
campo sobre el circuito iba hacia
adentro en este caso del circuito e iba
hacia afuera en este otro cacho entonces
lo que pasaba es que se ejercía un
torque con respecto a este eje de acá y
por lo tanto el circuito empezaba a
girar entonces giraba y giraba azul
conforme iba girando llegábamos a esta
posición aquí todavía teníamos una
fuerza hacia adentro y aquí hacia afuera
pero ahora como esa fuerza no era
totalmente perpendicular al brazo de
rotación entonces ya no ejercía un
torque pues tan grande como acá pero de
todas formas él ejercía un torque y
seguía empujando esta cosa para que
siguiera girando hasta que llegábamos a
este punto al llegar a este punto así
visto de lado ya no había nada de torque
porque justo el brazo de rotación es
paralelo a la fuerza y otra vez esto del
torque tiene que ver con un producto
cruz
lo tanto aquí nos daba que ese producto
crucero era cero bueno no lo vimos así
pero esa es la forma de argumentar lo
bueno lo mismo pasaba en ambos lados
verdad tanto en el verde citó como el
morado no había nada de torque pero
aunque no hubiera torque todavía
cargábamos una cierta velocidad angular
o sea todavía la traíamos y entonces eso
iba a hacer que esta cosa que este
circuito girará un poquito más en su eje
de rotación hasta pasar esta posición de
90 grados y quedará algo más o menos de
este estilo
bueno tenías que pensar que iba a pasar
pero vamos a verlo vamos a verlo ahorita
entonces va a quedar algo de este estilo
entonces ahora tenemos este lado este
lado este va paka paka
más o menos algo de ese estilo
y aquí teníamos esto bueno entonces
sigue girando sigue girando y que el
lado es cual lado bueno pues este lado
rosa que venía de acá empezó a girar
paso acá empezó a girar ahora es este
porque siguió girando es este lado
grande va y el lado verde que aquí
estaba el fondo ahora se convierte en
este lado verde de acá entonces mi
pregunta es ahora cómo están las cosas
pues vamos a ver lo de la corriente si
por ahí tenemos una corriente
y hacia dónde va pues bueno primero pasa
por el lado verde y luego por el lado
rosa entonces la corriente va así otra
forma de pensarlo es que este lado
positivo siguió siendo positivo por acá
aquí sigue siendo negativo y entonces la
corriente
la corriente ahora fluye en este sentido
va en este sentido de acá pero bueno
ahora qué sucedería con la fuerza que
ejerce el campo magnético pues vamos a
ver cada cachito qué sucede con el lado
de acá con el lado con el lado rosita
con el lado morado o rosa bueno pues
ahora la corriente va para arriba verdad
la corriente va para arriba entonces la
longitud está en la fórmula también va
para arriba y el campo magnético va
hacia la izquierda es esta regla de la
mano derecha por lo tanto ahora el campo
magnético está ejerciendo una fuerza
hacia hacia afuera hacia afuera en el
lado izquierdo antes de ejercer una
fuerza hacia adentro en el lado
izquierdo pero ahora va hacia afuera y
del lado derecho pasa lo contrario como
lo puedes verificar utilizando la regla
de la mano derecha pero ahorita no me
voy a meter mucho en eso bueno entonces
qué va a pasar qué va a pasar pues ahora
tenemos que esta cosa está empujando
hacia afuera y aquí hacia adentro y
entonces se va a invertir el torque y
por lo tanto se va a invertir la
rotación
o sea ahora vamos a tener que salir de
este lado y entra de este lado de acá
creo que es un poco más fácil de
pensarlo si piensas en todo el proceso
osea empiezas aquí empieza a girar sale
de este lado sale de este lado luego
entra entonces ahora se convierte en
este que es la posición de 90 grados
gira tantito más por el momento angular
que lleva que llega acá que lleva
entonces llega a este punto de acá
entonces luego va a seguir girando un
poquito más quizás hasta llegar a una
posición similar a esto pero la
corriente ahora está invertida ahora va
así y por lo tanto ahora va a girar al
revés va entonces esa es la idea va a
seguir oscilando así y así y entonces
tenemos un problema si queremos hacer un
motor verdad si queremos hacer un motor
eléctrico entonces tendríamos que
encontrar alguna forma de pues no sé o
bien invertir la corriente al llegar a
esta posición o bien invertir el campo
magnético pero también tenemos otro
problema un poco más práctico que es que
si hacemos que gire gira y dirigiré como
aquí arriba sigue habiendo pues partes
del circuito entonces los cables se
pueden enredar también tenemos que
arreglar eso
y bueno resulta que la solución para
para todas esas cosas es un conmutador
déjame contarte que es un conmutador y
para eso voy a pasar aquí abajo para
tener un poco más de espacio vamos a
seguir pensando que tenemos un campo que
va de derecha a izquierda
entonces el campo magnético que sigue
yendo de de derecha a izquierda va y
aquí voy a poner esta cosa que es un
conmutador entonces otra vez voy a
pintar el circuito va entonces hasta
ahorita todo va igual
tenemos ahí el circuito que parece como
una como una botella de perfume o algo
así y lo que vamos a hacer es que ahora
en este extremo vamos a poner unas
clavijas especiales vamos a poner unas
clavijas especiales que permiten el paso
de corriente hacia el resto del circuito
imagínate que aquí está el resto por
aquí está la batería
va que permiten el paso de corriente y
que ahorita te voy a contar que hacen de
especial hasta ahorita todo va igual a
quién le voy a poner más menos entonces
la corriente también sigue fluyendo así
sigue siendo paka paka paka paka
bueno se ve la idea verdad así lo
compacta
ok y lo que vamos a hacer o sea este
aparato es el conmutador lo que vamos a
hacer es poner el eje del circuito pero
no llegando hasta allá sino nada más
como a esta altura más o menos como por
ahí
y vamos a jugar otra vez con el campo
para ver qué pasa y ahorita te cuento
qué hacen estas clavijas pero otra vez
verdad tenemos de la misma corriente de
que acá abajo en la acá arriba en la
misma dirección
entonces utilizando la regla de la mano
derecha una vez más vamos a tener vamos
a tener que aquí entra que aquí entra la
fuerza va hacia adentro y de este lado
sale de este lado sale entonces una vez
más vamos a estar girando como giraba
arriba verdad así
entonces sigue girando y sigue girando y
sigue pasando la corriente pero va a
suceder algo especial cuando llegamos a
la posición vertical en la posición
vertical esta parte de arriba va a estar
igual y está va a estar así déjame
copiarla así igualita
hasta la batería luego viene para acá
acá
para cada vale pero lo importante es que
ahora cuando llegamos a esta posición la
parte de abajo del circuito se
desconecta de la pila entonces cómo se
vería déjame poner el eje de rotación
para que sea un poquito más claro
y entonces ahí está el eje de rotación
otra vez empezó a girar así entonces en
frente tenemos el lado morado el lado
morado
por ahí atrás cito tenemos el lado verde
el lado verde pero las clavijas de esta
parte del circuito ya se desconectaron
puedes imaginarte quién está por allá
quién está por acá no te imagínate telas
por ahí de alguna forma pero chistes que
están desconectadas entonces qué sucede
en este momento deja de ocurrir la
corriente
aquí ya no está pasando la corriente
verdad porque ya no está conectado el
circuito no hay forma de que fluya sin
embargo en este momento pues vamos a
tener todavía un poquito de momento
angular justo como nos pasaba acá arriba
todavía tenemos un poquito de momento
angular entonces nuestro invento este
nuestro cacho de circuito que está aquí
abajo va a seguir rotando tantito
frotando tantito más va y luego se va a
volver a poner en contacto con el
circuito porque las clavijas se van a
volver a conectar pero ahora volteadas
va bueno en esta posición vertical no
hay torque y pasa un poquito más se
vuelven a conectar llevamos un poquito
de inercia y qué crees que suceda
después bueno pues te voy a dejar
pensando en eso para que para que
meditas un poco en qué crees que suceda
y vamos a platicar
de las consecuencias de este aparato en
el siguiente vídeo
hasta la próxima